regard mais c'est moi tout d'abord que
souhaitait la bienvenue à tous ceux
beaucoup plus nombreux qu'à l'ordinaire
qui n'ont jamais siégé dans notre
hémicycle
pour elle c'est fait c'est toujours un
événement quand il ya des élections
législatives et quand lé nouveau député
qui arrive à l'assemblée et là il y en a
beaucoup parce qu'on à 75% de
l'assemblée nationale qui a été
renouvelé ce qui est énorme sur 577
députés
il y en a 4 131 qui sont nouvellement
élu on a un groupe majoritaire la
république en marche qui est les tories
qu il ya 308 députés qui sont élus en
2017 ce sont des macros nist ils sont
élus en fait sur le seul programme d'
emmanuel macron une responsabilité cette
responsabilité c'est aussi de ma
d'appliquer le programme des manuels
macro et puis après je serai quelqu'un
et lui constructif et donc j'apporterai
aussi ma pierre personnel cet édifice
qui est le programme des manuels y en a
beaucoup qui n'ont jamais fait de
politique et qui ne sont jamais venus à
l'assemblée nationale
là y'a des images exclusives à -cp où on
a pu nous avoir l'autorisation de poser
notre caméra et on voit ces députés
rentrer là avec toute la fraîcheur
qu'ils ont finalement parce qu'ils sont
pas politiques vraiment tu fais système
parlementaire
mais chez 2k sénateurs la première j'ai
vu ça qu'est la télé
est ce que ça vous dérange de me prendre
en photo tous les trois gilbert collard
mais en fait ce qui est le plus étonnant
c'est pour moi ce groupe d'insoumis tous
les journalistes sont autour d'eux et
eux ils avancent y déambulent comme ça
on sent qu'ils prennent un plaisir fou
et puis nous on a la chance lcp d'avoir
notre caméra à l'intérieur où on les
découvre en train de se préparer parce
que c'est vrai que les insoumis souvent
ils ont un peu la chemise qui sort du
pot talo est un petit peu débraillé mais
là c'est vraiment jour deux jours de
fête
si tu veux la faire super bien
revoyez qu'il faut faire un petit creux
donc ce soit parfait sinon ça fait trop
rigide voyez il faut que ça infogère
romanesque légèrement négliger et puis
après il va se tourner vers un député
qui est très proche de lui qui est
alexis corbière et il va à son tour les
des affaires sans être cravate parce que
j'imagine qu alexis corbière a du mal à
le faire ou n'a pas l'habitude de le
faire
ça c'est une image qui est effectivement
assez marquante est assez touchante
finalement de ses premiers pas de
nouveau nés au député à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]